le virologue que je suis en particulier
qui est dans une région de la région
parisienne parmi les plus touchées
extrêmement inquiet j'ai toute ma
famille à la guadeloupe j'ai beaucoup
d'amis à la martinique et guyane et je
regarde ça avec beaucoup d'inquiétude
parce que il ya bien les gens qui me
font rire c'est beaucoup d'inquiétude la
première raison c'est que le taux de
vaccination étant très faible on a
assisté à une hécatombe ces derniers
temps beaucoup de gens sont morts
beaucoup beaucoup de gens sont morts et
le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
que on va comme les chiffres ont baissé
parce qu'ils avaient le confinement une
fois pour enlever le confinement on va
lever aussi la circulation du virus et
quand le virus va arriver il va trouver
une population qui n'est pas vacciné
mais il va se répandre à nouveau et je
crains et je le dis je les dis je crée
véritablement une cinquième vague qui
soit autant sinon plus meurtrière pense
que la question qui est posée quand un
virus par définition c'est limite le
views est ce que vous savez qu'il ya
plus de 300000 varillon 12 corona qui
sont apparus depuis on a détecté depuis
alors c'est vrai que le bal en delta il
a pris le dessus c'est lui qui se
développe est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en
martinique alors qu'au début de la
première vague vous aviez le voir alpha
qui étaient plus nombreux petit à petit
en delta s'est imposée et aujourd'hui
les chiffres que j'ai avec 97 % devant
delta qui circulent en martinique et on
sait qu'il est plus virulent r d qui
s'adapte beaucoup mieux et c'est ça qui
me fait être inquiet devant cette
situation où il ya probablement blocage
c'est cela alors que faire docteur est
ce qu'il ya une solution pour éviter
cette cinquième vague écoutez le la
solution c'est que moi je crois que nous
avons pris l'initiative avec tous nos
confrères le guen de matinée galles et
de la réunion dans tandis qu'en réunion
ça se passe beaucoup beaucoup mieux on a
levé d'ailleurs la situation du genre je
pense qu'un réunion ils sont vaccinés à
un niveau plus élevé le vaccin c'est
quoi le vaccin il empêche au virus de
rentrer chez vous donc il empêche de
faire des dégâts il n'empêche pas en
conséquent qu'une population comme la
nôtre qui est très sensible fait qu'un
tiers des antillais ont des comorbidités
un tiers d'entre nous on hypertendus et
les diabétiques où on est on voit là et
on a donc cette question il se transmet
par voie orale il se transmet par les
aérosols donc très très faste il faut
pas l'attraper autant que faire se peut
et on y recourt de plus en plus ce qu'on
appelle le conduit de long des gens qui
ont un peu de signes très peu de cinéma
continue après avoir toute une série
notamment le col de la concentration
j'ai des collègues qui sont incapables
de se concentrer ça fait partie de sa
vie en question qu'on ne dit pas alors
c'est une question de la psychiatrie
très bien docteur alors là la
suppression des tests pcr et de
l'isolément pour les personnes vaccinées
qui se rendent aux antilles françaises
elle inquiète certains est-ce que selon
vous c'est une mesure adéquate ben
écoute et on aide un système
d'inquiétude
effectivement et donc du coup tout ce
qui va paraître ne allégée à lundi où la
situation est bien ça va ça va a été
appelé les gens moi ce que je crois moi
je vous dis en tant que virologues c'est
que les personnes vaccinées nos qualités
c'est qu'elles sont premièrement
beaucoup moins sensibles à l'infection
et peuvent être infectés mais dans les
24 à 48 avons éliminé les russes
deuxièmement elles sont beaucoup moins
transmetteur de dix fois moins trash
metal quoi quand le virus arrive il est
bloqué la charge du risque beaucoup
moins important et troisièmement elle ne
seront pas hospitalisés ces personnes
elles ne feront pas de formes graves et
elle ne mourront pas ces personnes
vaccinées alors en fait quelqu'un qui
est vaccinée au contraire il a des
éléments de protection que son organisme
a fabriqué du fait de la vaccination